If you are working without papers in this year 2 024,
you have to know
that you have the same labor rights as
the Spaniards
or that those who have papers
but it is not from 6 months or 1 year ago,
or 2 or 3,
not that 1 new law has come out.
The law ended in the year 2000,
that is,
you have been there for 24 years
that people without papers
has the same labor rights
than the Spaniards,
minus unemployment because it is not quoted.
What does that mean?
Well,
that your salary today
because it has not yet been discovered.
The new minimum wage is €1,080 per month.
For 14 payments you are entitled to 30 days of vacation,
you are entitled to 1 Christmas payment,
you are entitled to 1 June payment
and if you lose your job because of any misfortune
or resign,
you are entitled to 1 termination.
And if you ask for a job because you have been fired,
you are entitled to 1 compensation for dismissal.
You know.
Remember that we defend your rights throughout Spain,
do not send money in advance and if there is no result
we do not charge